cloud console is our powerful all-in-one
graphical tool to manage your Google
cloud platform resources regardless of
their data center location in this video
we'll cover the core features to get you
ready to build and manage your
applications on GCP let's get started
[Music]
GCP resources are the fundamental
components that make up the Google cloud
services typical examples include
compute engine virtual machines cloud
pub/sub topics cloud storage buckets app
engine instances and so forth resources
are organized hierarchically using
projects and folders projects allowed to
group resources together and are the
first level of that hierarchy all
resources must belong to exactly one
project so a given virtual machine or
Kuban engine cluster belongs to one
project optionally projects can belong
to organizations and provide centralized
visibility and control across all
projects in a given org you can further
organize your company departments or
teams into folders folders can contain
both projects and subfolders for added
flexibility this entire hierarchy offers
an ownership chain which means that when
you delete a parent all its resources
are also deleted it also provides the
basis for access control policy
inheritance you can easily navigate
across your GCB projects using the scope
picker and cop console switching
projects will tailor the view to that
project and all of its child resources
GCP services are accessible in the
left-hand navigation menu organized by
product area including Big Data compute
networking and so forth the home
dashboard provides a high-level overview
of the selected GCP project highlighting
key metrics billing and other useful
information you can customize your
dashboard freely any card can be hid and
shown and reordered on the page with the
Activity Stream you'll be able to
understand all the activities that occur
across your DCP resources in one place
you can see which projects have been
updated what your teammates are doing or
audit access to your GCP resources you
can also filter
to the feed to find exactly what you
need the search bar in cloud console
allows you to quickly access Google
cloud platform products and any of your
resources across GCB simply search for
App Engine or the name of one of your
projects the api's and services section
of the console is where you can manage
one of our hundreds of AP is enable or
disable a service generate or revoke
credentials monitor requests and so
forth this includes all of our GCP
machine learning google maps g suite and
analytics api is if you ever get stuck
or need help navigating the world of GCP
our support team is here to help your
support cases relating to both
development questions and production
issues are all accessible right from the
console navigation menu Google Cloud
Identity and Access Management or cloud
iam enables you to manage and create
permissions for your DCP resources as
your team grows you can grant access to
teammates using the I am in admin
section add users groups or service
accounts and assign them any number of
roles to grant them the permission they
need as you can see there are many
predefined roles to choose from not just
admin and developer Google Cloud shell
provides you with command line access to
your cloud resources directly from your
browser you can easily manage your
projects and resources without having to
install anything on your system cloud
shell is accessible right from your
browser in cloud console and is powered
by a small virtual machine with
persistent disk space and up-to-date
software for all of your development
needs it even comes with a web editor
the billing section of the cloud console
is where you manage billing accounts and
link your projects to them a billing
account is essentially a payment method
one or more credit card information or
bank account details a project that does
not have billing enable that means that
does not have an Associated billing
account will just not be able to use GCV
products beyond their features you can
change the billing account for a given
project at any point in time you can set
budget alerts to help you manage costs
and setup triggered actions for projects
or accounts as well you can also
generate billing exports as well as
reports to better understand your spent
finally cloud console is also available
as if
mobile app for both Android and iOS it
can help you understand the health of
your services at a glance with
customizable graphs CPU network usage
QPS and so forth and show you any
billing alerts it allows you to manage
incidents and alerts navigate through
error and crash reports you can also
start and stop compute engine instances
navigate through their logs and even SSH
into them other products such as App
Engine cloud storage and cloud SQL are
also supported I can't wait to see what
you build next with cloud console if you
liked this video please like subscribe
comment share and look forward to more
GCB essentials videos
[Music]
you